so we've used this guy as a
stepping-stone now I'm going to try and
have a look at this guy here and see
what we can get from that
okay so underneath this I want us to
write a little subheading leave space
for this though it's a bit of a spoiler
what the subheading will be but I'm
going to give you an example we're going
to try and work out we're looking at two
cubed where we two cubed this is what
happens we know what happens when you
multiply stuff what happens when you
divide I want to know for example what
happens if I divide two cubed by 2 cubed
okay now think think carefully some of
you got that really quick I want you to
make sure we all get there right using
this using this law what should we get
as the answer out the end what are we
thinking yeah Jessica keeps on it again
but just louder so everyone can hear -
raise the power 0 now who agrees does
this seem reasonable to you give me a
thumbs up if you agree or a thumbs down
if you're that no no I think it's
something else I'd love to see I'm
waiting to see you've got no
disagreement no I'm like I'm like
non-committal I'm not sure what to do
here David what do you got I can't see
your hands man what's happening hey you
were sideways I don't know okay let's
think about this right I can hands down
thank you we've got this stepping stone
here right can we use this stepping
stone to try and make sense of whether
this is right or not Marik what do you
think you right so when we divide things
which have the same base right we
subtract their powers yeah so so three
take away three last I checked is zero
right so that that does follow but wait
a second you know what two cubed is
don't you it's what's it actually equal
to it's actually equal to eight if I
gave you a question 8 divided by 8 what
would you say the answer was yeah
otherwise you'd say it's 1 right in fact
if it was 8 divided by 8 or like 50
million divided by 50 million anything
divided by itself should give you
one right so hold on a second what we're
saying is that this is also equal to one
now this is really weird to me right
because this is multiply 2 by itself
three times and apparently this is
multiply 2 by itself no times the
multiplication is happening so this is
what we're seeing here make what are you
thinking okay so one is just a regular
part of what happens when you divide
numbers when it's equal okay yeah that's
right now there's another way that we
can convince ourselves that we're not
like going crazy okay let's just think
about when numbers are getting bigger so
if I said to the power of one you should
all tell me that's equal to it's equal
to two very good I just had to check it
was one of them I knew it was one of
them what happens if I square 4 what
happens if I keep your a Tommy this
let's go one more for good measure 2
power 4
ok now what's happening how am I going
down as I increase the power right from
2 to 4 you you'd both like to do from 4
to 8 you multiply by 2 you keep you keep
going right I could go to 32 and 64 and
so on okay so that's what happening
what's happening as the power gets
bigger what happens is the power gets
smaller what's happening yeah those what
do you say yeah we're going to sort of
hit if you really want to get a handle
in this right we can do it in one fell
swoop right from 4 to 3 I / - right from
3 to 3 to 2 I divided by 2 divided by 2
one more time if I divide by 2 again
what should I get 1
this was not where I intended for this
lesson to go but just because we're so
curious what if I went one more time
what would the power be if I decreased
it by one one more time so ended
negative one so what if I follow the
pattern I'm dividing by two every time
so what should I get what's 1/2
0.5 or 1/2 right what we got fractions
in here right now like I said I'll put
this in another color because we aren't
mainly focusing on this today but isn't
that interesting
that what we've used is this very
straightforward thing we saw before and
we're like oh I can use this as a
stepping stone to other knowledge we
summarized this power of a power in this
way remember I told you to write give
space for some petty but I didn't tell
you what that something was
there's something I'd like you to put
here is the zero power when the power is
zero
like me it's to the power 0 or 5 to the
power of zero or like I don't know so
hand it to the power of zero now let's
not make Sandra power 0 but that's ok if
we did you always get one right I could
change all these numbers to threes or
fives you'd still get one so in in red
I'm gonna write down the bottom here any
number absolutely any number raised to
the power of zero it's always going to
be say with me one every time no matter
what number you throw in there okay